hello there answering the question about
corruption from the world economic forum
in davos question is what are the things
that the leaders can do to resist or
eliminate corruption so the developing
countries can lead the new generation
there's an initiative that the young
global leaders started a few years ago
here in Davos called the global business
open the idea the global business of is
very similar to the Hippocratic oath
that doctors take in order to practice
medicine and the global business of
basically is is a pledge that we're
trying to get business leaders to take
to transform the value systems
recognizing that the ultimate purpose of
management is to serve society by
bringing any other people and resources
to create sustainable and inclusive
prosperity that that doesn't serve just
one single another two alone and I think
if we can have business leaders
political leaders take this this global
businesses around the world and
implement it inside business schools and
leadership schools then we can begin to
enforce it the same way that if you were
to break your Hippocratic oath you might
in many cases lose your right to
practice medicine to be a doctor so
that's my answer hello pandavas and
thank you